per 20
morto
io parlerò di niente parlerò parlerò di
aria quindi potete stare tranquilli
sereni non serve concentrazione quindi
ce la facciamo tutta d'un fiato e
proverò a raccontare un po la mia
esperienza sono sono responsabile del
design per un'azienda che lavora nel
settore del nel settore del trattamento
dell'aria e io mi occupo proprio di
progettare intorno all'area cerco di
rendere visibile e materiale quello che
generalmente non è visibile e il
materiale cioè l'aria cerco quindi di
immaginare oggetti e situazioni che
possono dare valore all'aria credo
quindi di essere la persona più adatta
per poter parlare in un talk che ha come
come tema aspire twins paese visto che
il mio lavoro consiste proprio nell
essere ispirato dall aspirazione
voi direte che razza di lavoro fa questo
tutti vorrebbero essere ispirati
dall'aspirazione di fumi no ogni tanto
ogni tanto faccio anche il designer
quando passa l'effetto faccio anche il
design
ma cosa significa oggi fare design fare
design è una parola inflazionata abusata
utilizzata spesso in modo improprio che
banalizza quello che è il reale percorso
che dà vita a prodotti che possono
essere definiti tali
quante volte sentiamo dire facciamo così
che più di design
sì perché oppure quando qualcuno non
riesce a capire il senso delle cose dice
ah boh e di design quasi come se fosse
colpa mia e quindi il design è qualcosa
che viene trattato male
tutti sono designer per un giorno quando
si parla di design
quando si parla di nuovi prodotti
affiorano sempre tanti dubbi e tante
perplessità sulle strade possibilità per
correre qual è la strada giusta forma e
funzione mi viene il porci collo durato
effimero essenzialità recesso lusso
semplicità e il design deve dare
risposta a questi dubbi con scelte
creative e produttive design inteso come
designare dare un senso ai prodotti uno
scopo è una missione vivo vivo il design
come uno stato mentale come un qualcosa
che tende alla bellezza
quando si parla di bellezza si si entra
in un campo delicato perché si entra
nella sfera del soggettivo la solita
frase non è bello ciò che è bello ma è
bello ciò che piace
ma in realtà che cos'è la bellezza la
bellezza per me el emozione estetica
delle cose la bellezza e tutto ciò che
ci lascia senza fiato tutto ciò che ci
fa ridere tutto ciò che ci fa piacere
agli occhi e all'animo un quadro una
bella canzone una poesia un tramonto un
bel paesaggio un bel paio di scarpe con
i tacchi perché no anche quelle bellezze
quindi tutte queste cose sono bellezze o
meglio possono essere bellezza perché in
realtà un tramonto che è la cosa più
bella del mondo styla con la tua ragazza
un paesaggio bellissimo lo stesso
tramonto
il giorno dopo la tua ragazza è ancora
là ma è con un altro lo stesso tramonto
non è più così bello diventa la cosa più
brutta del mondo quindi possiamo dire
che la bellezza in realtà non è nelle
cose ma è dentro di noi la bellezza sono
le emozioni che tutto ciò che ci
circonda riesce riescono a suscitare e
il design deve scalare proprio in quelle
emozioni deve essere in grado di trovare
quelle emozioni quando disegno un nuovo
prodotto quando immagino qualcosa di
nuovo parto sempre da da una visione di
un'immagine emozionante che contiene
proprio quelle emozioni di cui parlavo
prima
e la visione di quello che vorrei che
sentisse la persona davanti al mio
prodotto quindi immagino una scena e
questa scena e la parte finale quindi
pratt praticamente posso dire che
paradossalmente il mio processo creativo
parte dalla fine e poi da lì comincia
tutto il resto
comincia a pensare il prodotto però ogni
prodotto ha una storia differente
complessa e lunga da raccontare ma voi
che vi ritroverete davanti a quel
prodotto
vedrete solo la parte finale non sapete
niente di questa storia e su quel
prodotto è coerente con l'immagine
iniziale se quel prodotto emozionerà
allo stesso modo
allora quel prodotto sarà scelta tra
dieci cento mille altri prodotti
questa la leggo non posso uscire dal
cerchio rosso perché mi hanno detto che
si apre la botola
la bellezza citando leon battista
alberti quindi non è mia e la somma di
tutte quelle parti messe insieme in
maniera tale che non è necessario
aggiungere né togliere niente né
alterare questo l'ho aggiunto io e il
design rappresenta l'espressione della
bellezza attraverso gli oggetti una
frase molto forte che parla di un ideale
di bellezza parla della perfezione che è
qualcosa di irraggiungibile
però ogni designer dovrebbe tendere ad
essa proprio per cercare il
miglioramento continuo e come si
migliora si migliora
ascoltando si migliora cercando di
essere sempre un passo avanti ai tempi
mettendo in discussione tutto quello che
generalmente viene considerato ovvio
bisogna intuire le realtà circostanti
cambiamenti delle genti della gente i
loro bisogni i loro desideri i loro
sogni i loro cambiamenti bisogna avere
fiuto verso il nuovo vivo le intuizioni
come la parte iniziale di un progetto
ogni idea nasce da una da un'intuizione
e poi grazie al design le intuizioni
possono avere vita possono diventare dei
prodotti il design non può prescindere
dall'innovazione l'innovazione intesa
come cambiamento ma non cambiamento fino
a se stesso cambiamento inteso come
miglioramento della vita delle persone e
l'innovazione deve essere in grado di
accorciare la distanza tra la tecnologia
e alle persone
la tecnologia che tanto ci piace ci
affascina però fa paura come un animale
feroce la guardiamo tutti quanti che
bello che bello no a casa mia non entra
quindi sembra inavvicinabile e il design
deve fare proprio questo deve
addomesticare la tecnologia deve domarla
deve renderla qualcosa di più vicino
all'uomo cercando di esaltarne anche i
vantaggi
quindi per me il design nel momento
innovativo per eccellenza tutto quello
che abbiamo detto finora attribuisce al
design un ruolo veramente importante ma
in realtà non serve a niente se non si
fanno se non si fanno i conti con un
elemento molto importante nella fase di
sviluppo e ideazione di un prodotto la
vendita ogni azienda
ogni azienda di qualsiasi settore
merceologico di qualsiasi natura ha un
solo scopo vende e per vendere un
prodotto questo deve rispondere a un
bisogno
ho un bisogno potrebbe creare deve
essere posizionato sul mercato nel modo
corretto
devo avere un costo competitivo deve
essere producibile secondo l'assetto
industriale dell'azienda e vendibile
secondo i canali dell'azienda
ed ecco che quindi il design diventa
qualcosa di molto più complesso perché
in ogni scelta
le variabili diventano tantissime e le
possibilità infinite
le aziende tanto più sono grandi tanto
più vivono di processi che tendono a
creare delle regole per replicare e per
avere dei risultati efficaci del tipo
premi il pulsante arriva l'altro molto
spesso si prova a fare anche con il
design questa cosa mettiamo il design a
processo ma per sua natura il design non
può essere razionalizzata e processato
perché dipende dalle persone
se noi prendiamo per esempio un bilancio
si è fatto secondo determinate regole
anche se lo faccio fare a mille persone
differenti il risultato sarà sempre
uguale al contrario il design per quante
regole posso mettere se lo faccio fare a
mille persone differenti avrà mille
prodotti differenti proprio perché il
processo creativo sarà sempre differente
fabici ce la fai a fare a disegnare una
cappa in una settimana
non lo so devo pensarci devo vedere
quando arriva l'idea creativa sa bene
dai una settimana allora cioè come se
fosse una pillola prende la pillola per
due giorni mattina e sera stesso giorno
arriva alla creatività e poi ai
disegnate il prodotto riguarda vediamo
un attimo ok non ti do una settimana ti
do sette giorni
questo è quello che si fa con il design
quindi il design va oltre quello che è
l'ordine il metodo il design e
creatività qualcosa di differente
immaginazione intuizione per la
creatività quando viene viene
quando ho cominciato a disegnare cup
questo prodotto era legato a un
paradigma di oggetto posizionato in
orizzontale sul piano perché l'aria
calda fatta sola verso l'alto e la forma
era esclusivamente funzionale larga
sotto per accogliere quanto a privare
possibile stretta sopra per contenere il
motore e le tubazioni in 14 anni ho
cercato di cambiare sempre le regole
ho cercato di immaginare qualcosa di
diverso
ho cercato di usare la tecnologia per
andare oltre per creare oggetti
innovativi
ho cercato di pensare in modo differente
e le cappe si sono trasformate in
qualcosa di differente
oggi vado veloce
i prodotti sono veri e propri elementi
d'arredo sono diventate delle lampade
dei lampadari dove è la luce la cosa
principale non più l'aspirazione
l'aspirazione c'è lo fa ma tu guardi la
luce sono diventati dei quadri dove
grazie al modo nuovo di aspirare grazie
a studi fluidodinamici non è più
necessario stare in orizzontale sul
piano diventano delle tele diventano
delle forme geometriche di estrema
semplicità diventano delle sculture
diventano oggetti in grado di
caratterizzare e valorizzare l'ambiente
in quest'anno diventano oggetti inediti
che sono frutto della combinazione unica
di forme materiali e colori con
soluzioni tecnologiche e funzionali
rivoluzionari ma per fare queste cose
bisogna cambiare prospettiva bisogna
guardare le cose da un punto di vista
differente
oggi la domanda che mi pongo o quello
che il mio punto di partenza quando devo
disegnare un nuovo prodotto non è come
disegnare il nuovo prodotto
no ma è devo risolvere un problema devo
trovare una soluzione a una necessità è
un'esigenza quindi cambiano le cose
perché il mio problema è l'aspirazione
dei fumi quella che mi ispira tanto non
è il prodotto in sé
ed ecco che quindi si parte da una tela
vuota c'è solo il problema all esigenza
è da lì che parte tutto e quindi solo in
questo modo le cose possono essere
cambiati solo in questo modo possono
possono nascere le cose più innovative
solo capovolgendo il modo di pensare
pensare in modo differente e le cose si
sono capovolte veramente perché oggi
l'aspirazione non avviene più dall'alto
come con le cappe tradizionali ma viene
dal basso ed è stata integrata
all'interno del piano cottura un
qualcosa di rivoluzionario nelle cucine
qualcosa che cambia proprio il modo il
punto di vista in cucina perché offre
possibilità nuove dal valore da valore
allo spazio dal valore proprio alla
cooking esperienze e il design diventa
espressione di tutto questo diventa
semantica diventa un racconto diventa il
racconto di quello che vuoi che il
prodotto di che il prodotto si deve
raccontare da solo grazie al design con
uno di questi prodotti
quest'anno ho vinto il compasso d'oro
che penso sia il premio più importante
nell'ambito del design sia il
riconoscimento più grande che un
designer può avere la risposta ufficiale
si dà tanta soddisfazione un punto
d'arrivo un traguardo la realtà una
figata pazzesca
una roba che da da piccolo
[Applauso]
è una di quelle cose che da piccolo
sognava una cosa che dice chissà un
giorno è come dire voglio andare sulla
luna no chissà un giorno diventerà
famoso tool a fare un prodotto
anzi la mia cosa era chissà un giorno un
mio prodotto sarà realizzato avrò fatto
migliaia di cappa e tutte realizzate e
quando ero a ho cominciato a studiare
design il mio sogno era chissà un giorno
vincerò il compasso d'oro meno tatuerò
addosso e smetterò di lavorare non mi
sono fatto il tatuaggio
continuo a lavorare però continua avere
tanta voglia
continua a essere stimolato grazie a
questo perché dopo che vince il primo
dice magari è stata solo una stata solo
fortuna ne voglio un altro purtroppo
siamo fatti così e quindi cerco credo
che questo possa dare nuova linfa
creativa possa stimolare ancora e far sì
che ancora possa essere
ispirato dall aspirazione che vi
assicuro è tanto bello grazie
[Applauso]